i think i feel i could bring this up to
you because most people probably can't
bring it up to you but you and i share
something in common is
we both went both did
a long a show that lasted a long time
with someone who got in trouble i have
someone who is
uh you know allison uh she's you know
she was part of that nexium thing
and she's being tried and she probably
gets sentenced to
prison time and i didn't even know that
yeah she
and i worked with her for seven years
and it was kind of like holy well i
you know and so obviously laurie
laughlin you i mean
i'm sure you were close with her was
this a big surprise to you i i
i love her i love her and you know i've
been asked it a lot
i'm sure oh you have oh you have yeah
i've gotten whittled down
uh but you're tired you know i just love
her
and so that's uh
i don't know i'd like to i'd like to see
a lot of other people doing time
there's a lot worse people in the world
i i don't know
because we're in such a place where
no matter what i say i'm screwed you
know
and and i just love her
so that's that's where i am on that but
i know more people than that that have
been canceled
literally canceled their careers have
been cancelled due to
um you know uh
cancel culture things that had to do
with real serious stuff like
underage girls and stuff like that and
they
you know last year was a lot of
stand-ups just got
and actors i mean look what happened i
mean it was
it's um and a lot of it um
had no court trial but it was like it
was done and done
you know twitter can destroy you you can
destroy yourself on twitter
right i could write a tweet right now
that could literally
shut me down right now it's so easy
isn't that something